un bon soir lundi 30 novembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv soixante dix huit
c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
en quelques minutes voici les titres de
cette édition
la visite cet après midi de jean castex
attrape le premier ministre s'est rendu
dans les locaux de l'entreprise connaît
en compagnie des ministres du travail et
de la ville et des placements dans ce
centre de formation pour promouvoir
l'apprentissage avec le plan un jeune
une solution à défaut de pouvoir se
tenir cette année en raison de la crise
sanitaire les marchés de noël se
réinvente à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des créatrices proposent leurs produits
dans un événement virtuel initiative
également du côté de montigny le
bretonneux qui met les étals de son
marché de noël en ligne depuis
aujourd'hui et depuis samedi certaines
mesures d'allégement du confinement sont
entrées en vigueur réouverture des
commerces non essentiels mais aussi la
pratique sportive qui peut se faire et
désormais pendant trois heures dans un
rayon de 20km certaines disciplines sont
de nouveau autorisés comme le golf
reportage et nous reviendrons également
tout à l'heure aussi sur une
manifestation qui a réuni à 400
personnes du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines ce week-end contre la loi de
sécurité globale
[Musique]
la direction trappe donc pour commencer
avec cette visite de jean castex le
premier ministre s'est rendu aujourd'hui
à l'entreprise connaît en compagnie
d'elisabeth bornes ministre du travail
et de nadia et que ce député des
yvelines est désormais un ministre
délégué en charge de la ville sur place
pour suivre ce déplacement astrid
bergère will gregory c'est ici à trappes
dans l'entreprise connaît que la
délégation ministérielle s'est rendu
alors cette visite entre dans le cadre à
la fois de la réforme de l'apprentissage
de 2018 et du plan un jeune une solution
ce plan a été lancé cet été
et comme son nom l'indiqué il vise à
offrir à chaque jeune une solution ça
passe par des aides à l'embauché des
formations d accompagnement ou encore
des aides financières l'entreprise
connaissait un des leaders dans les
secteurs des ascenseurs et elle dispose
d'un centre de formation continue ici
l'entreprise forme donc des jeunes
majoritairement en apprentissage dans
plusieurs métiers techniciens de
maintenance commerciaux ou encore
électro mécaniciens et les buts de cette
visite donc c'était de rencontrer ces
jeunes qui participent à ces
apprentissages
astrid berges heures avec patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques une visite sur laquelle nous
reviendrons dans notre journal de demain
avec quelques réactions toujours dans
l'actualité c'est l'épidémie de kovy 19
qui est confiant son recul si l'on se
fie à ces derniers chiffres taux de
positivité en baisse au test qui est en
baisse tout d'incidence également un qui
est en baisse c'est à dire le nombre de
personnes contaminées pour cent mille
personnes sa baisse sur une semaine tout
comme le taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation en ile de france qui avait
atteint elle est quasi 100% aujourd'hui
c'est redescendu à 70 % ce qui reste
tout de même très élevé pour la première
fois depuis plusieurs semaines les
hospitalisations sont restés stables
dans le département
moins de patients sont également en
réanimation mais en une semaine 47
personnes supplémentaires ont succombé
du coronavirus dans les hôpitaux
yvelinois portant le nombre de victimes
à 889 depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
et d'ailleurs cette semaine saint
quentin en yvelines vous propose de vous
faire tester après une première
opération en septembre à destination des
entreprises
l'agglomération renouvelle ses journées
de dépistage pour cette fois ci tous les
habitants c'est au vélodrome national
situé à montigny le bretonneux à partir
de demain
mardi 1er décembre et une deuxième
journée aussi le mercredi 2 décembre
2000 tests anti génie qui seront
réalisés l'accès se fait sur rendez vous
auprès de l'application d'octo libre
c'est en raison de ces dernières
améliorations de données déco du coc
vite 19 qui emmanuel macron a décidé
d'alléger certaines mesures liées au
confinement la première étape a été
enclenchée à samedi dernier avec
notamment est la réouverture des
commerces dits non essentiels à la
proche des fêtes de fin d'année les
clients étaient nombreux pour venir
redécouvrir les boutiques
reportage aux clayes-sous-bois de justin
brasier de nicolas landry les commerces
ont rouvert ce week-end ici au centre
commercial one night in paris
le parking était plein dès 10h
commerçants et clients étaient ravis de
pouvoir retrouver les boutiques les
responsables ont préparé le terrain en
amont pour mettre en place le protocole
chaque magasin clairement indiqué sa
capacité d'accueil
ce qui permet aux clients de comprendre
si toutefois on est amené à attendre les
consignes sont à l'extérieur et donc
tous les clients peuvent largement dès
l'entrée met le gel
au revoir les consignes sanitaires et le
nombre de personnes maximum dans la
boutique les clients sont arrivés par
vagues pour profiter de ce premier week
end les ouvertures des commerces ravis
de pouvoir faire les boutiques et
commencer les achats de noël
premièrement pour aider les commerçants
je pense que c'est la première chose qui
me tient à coeur
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils ont souffert
énormément de la fermeture donc voilà on
attendait d'eux le premier jour pour
vous pour faire nos cadeaux enfin
commencer au moins à faire nos cadeaux
de noël
moi ça ne me gêne pas de sortir avec les
les mesures barrières et les précautions
à prendre
je continue à vivre malgré tout le mois
de décembre s'annonce bon selon cette
commerçante les achats en ligne ne
remplace pas le service en boutique
on va faire un carton je pense que les
gens ont vraiment attendu j'ai beaucoup
de clientes qui réclamait justement les
magasins et pas le commerce en ligne
mais bonne cliente ont besoin de ce
conseil de pouvoir essayer de pouvoir
toucher on apporte un service
supplémentaire pour ce premier week-end
de réouverture le centre commercial a
accueilli près de 30 de 1600 personnes
soit 21 % de fréquentation en plus sur
le week end par rapport à l'année
dernière
une autre mesure d'allègement fini la
règle d une heure un kilomètre pour
l'activité sportive les golfeurs
notamment ont pu reprendre foulé les
chemins refouler les greens on en
reparlera à la fin de ce journal à
suivre également les marchés noël un qui
se réinvente en pleine crise sanitaire
c'est dans un instant mais d'abord c'est
un texte un vous le savez qui fait
polémique notamment pour son article 24
qui encadre la diffusion d'image des
forces de l'ordre la loi sécurité
globale a été adopté en première lecture
par les députés la semaine dernière
samedi quatre cents personnes
manifestaient contre le texte devant le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux
c'était à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
associations et élus de gauche il
dénonce une loi jeudi je cite c'est
libère ce liberticide dans sa globalité
et en demandent le retrait écouter ses
interviews collectées par nicolas
d'andré ça n'apporte aucune sécurité
par contre effectivement ça apporte une
heure possibilité de répression plus
grande
d'autant plus que la loi
à mon avis ce n'est pas un hasard et
très mal écrite est donc plutôt que de
préciser certaines choses dans ce qui
existe elle amène du chou et 6-1 même du
soudan la loi eh bien ça veut dire qu'on
amène aussi essentiellement l'arbitraire
féministe déjà des textes de loin qui
permettent de protéger une identité des
policiers donc à mon sens cet article 24
et inutile
c'est des mauvaises lois pour tout le
monde parce que les policiers ils font
leur travail mais des fois il le faut un
peu mal et donc faudrait qu'on puisse
voir ce qu'il faut aussi pour lui que
des facettes toutes les images
malheureusement cette semaine nous avons
eu une preuve exceptionnel
de l'importance des images dans cette
arrestation de michel enfin dans ce
tabassage en règle de michel dans le
xviie nous pensons tous que s'il n'y
avait pas eu d'image cet homme là
n'auraient pas aucun moyen de se
défendre mais je vous le disais cet
article qui fait polémique l'article 24
qui a pour objet de protéger les
policiers contre la diffusion d'image
sur d'image dans la presse un dimanche
des policiers aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux
cet article 24 et accusé d'aller à
l'encontre de la liberté de la presse le
vote de ce texte est d'ailleurs
intervenue au moment de la révélation
des violences policières contre le
producteur michel éclair dans le xviie
arrondissement
écoutez à ce propos la députée des
yvelines marie lebey qui était l'invité
de patrice carmouze dans l'émission paf
quand on utilise l'article 24 quand on
cherche à le faire appliquer s'il devait
être adopté définitivement
et ça ne nuit pas à la liberté
d'informer au droit de la presse et ça
doit être avec l'intention manifeste de
nuire aux forces de l'ordre
or là on voit bien que la diffusion des
images dans le cadre de la sphère michel
est claire elle ne nuit pas aux
policiers elle permet d'informer elles
permettent d'alerter sur une bavure une
des rimes qui doit être fermement
sanctionnés
je crois que ce sont deux affaires
totalement différente en revanche moi je
suis pour cet article 24
peut-être qu'il doit être enrichi et
amélioré mais je crois que c'est de s'en
soucier du travail parlementaire
pour la simple et bonne raison que moi
je viens d'un département où il y a et
deux
représentant de la police mais aussi un
enseignant qui ont été assassinés et
notamment pour lesquelles on a diffusé
des images d'eux et on a donné des
informations personnelles sur sur leur
vie privée permettant à la fois de les
identifier et de les retrouver
et c'est avec avec cet article 24 c'est
ce contre quoi nous essayons de lutter
et on apprend en fin d'après-midi par la
voix de christophe castaner président du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale avec une
réécriture complète de l'article 24 sera
proposé tout autre chose à présent avec
les marchés de noël à défaut de pouvoir
se tenir en présentiel des créatrices de
saint quentin en yvelines ont trouvé une
alternative
elle propose des produits en ligne via
un marché virtuel justin brasier est
allé à leur rencontre
un marché de noël virtuel pour pallier
l'absence d'exposants cette année des
créatrices de saint quentin en yvelines
se sont réunis par le biais d'un groupe
facebook pour vendre leurs produits
une idée à l'initiative de cette
créatrice dans la mesure où tous les
marchés s'annuler les uns après les
autres il a fallu trouver un moyen de se
faire connaître de profiter un petit peu
de cette opportunité pour vendre nos
créations sur un autre biais
comme les réseaux sociaux allons la
création du groupe facebook date du 7
novembre dernier
chacune y va de sa publication pour
présenter ses créations j'ai un stock
que je prends en photo
donc ça fait une base pour que les
clients se rendent compte de ce dont il
s'agit et puis après deux options soit
en fait les clientes ont vu ce qu'ils
avaient en stock
la trousse par exemple et du coup a
décidé d'acheter celle là donc du coup
et on voit un petit message soit une
dizaine j'aime bien mais est ce que vous
l'avez dans une autre couleur à moi de
coudre en fait pour rester dans les
délais de noël voilà qui se rapproche au
total huit créatrice font partie du
marché de noël virtuel au catalogue
créations textiles peintures ou encore
zéro déchet une initiative locale dans
le domaine de la création artisanale
nous notre cible souhaitée c'est
vraiment la clientèle de proximité de
faire fonctionner le bouche à oreille et
puis de proposer des produits qui sont
plus locale que ça c'est pas possible
quoi enfin je veux dire on est tout de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines montigny
guyancourt voisins donc c'est vraiment
du fait main c'est que l'on casse et de
l'artisanat
le marché de noël virtuelle des
créatrices de saint quentin en yvelines
a déjà attiré plus de 700 personnes à
montigny le bretonneux pas de
traditionnel marché de noël non plus
hein il a l'habitude de se tenir chaque
année du côté de la ferme du manet c'est
l'un des principaux d'ailleurs dans le
coin mais la ville s'est réorganisé a
décidé de proposer cette année ses étals
en ligne un catalogue interactif est à
retrouver sur le site internet de la
commune qui met en avant les exposants
qui étaient prévus sur ce marché de noël
les artisans de saint quentin en
yvelines on parle de cette initiative
avec josé cache un bon soir par son
maire adjoint en charge de la culture et
de l'événementiel à
montigny-le-bretonneux également avec
nous par visioconférence valérie via le
bonsoir bonsoir à tous
bonsoir à vous artisans du côté
d'elancourt maître voilier alors vous
réparez fabriquer dévoilez-vous
fabriquer aussi des accessoires de mode
à partir de voiles de bateau que vous
récupérez alors des voiles de bateaux
mais aussi d'autres voile on va en
parler tout à l'heure d'habitude josé
cachin gisèle ya ce marché de noël qui
se tient du côté de la ferme du manège
si on prend l'édition 2019 c'était 130
exposants qui étaient sur deux jours de
fête à la ferme la forme du manet du
coup c'est important pour vous pourquoi
proposer cette initiative malgré
l'annulation d'avoir une initiative tout
de même en ligne qu'ils puissent se
tenir bien évidemment important alors
comme vous le dites très bien on avait
130 exposants 17 mille visiteurs près de
17 mille visiteurs pendant le week-end
il nous paraissait incontournable de
trouver une solution pour essayer de de
parer à cette annulation à la fois pour
répondre aux attentes de notre public de
mes visiteurs mais aussi pour apporter
notre soutien auprès des différents
exposants
qui était encore présent sur 7 sur cette
édition 2020 ça c'est l'un des objectifs
soutenir ces commerçants ces exposants
qui était prévu aussi dans une période
crise sanitaire crise économique c'est
pas facile pour eux en ce moment c'est
pas facile pour eux en ce moment on
essaie nous d'apporter notre soutien à
tous niveaux d'ailleurs lors du dernier
conseil municipal une motion a été votée
pour pour faire part de tout le soutien
qu'on pouvait leur apporter
l'initiative de mettre en place ce
marché de noël en ligne nous est venue
rapidement à l'esprit oms on a senti on
a senti un réel engouement des exposants
a participé à ce catalogue pas tous
essentiellement parce que certains
d'entre eux ne souhaitent pas ou n'ont
pas les moyens techniques de faire de la
vente en ligne
mais voilà en tout cas l'initiative a
été prise
je pense que ça va bien fonctionner ça a
bien démarré en tout cas et vous le dis
avec beaucoup de visiteurs l'année
passée donc c'est de leur proposer aussi
ces produits sont attachés à ces
produits
l'artisanat local les produits du
terroir quelque chose alors ils les
petites habitudes
les petites habitudes annuel voilà les
gens se déplacent s'adresse bien souvent
aux mêmes commerçants en cette période
et puis je pense que naturellement il ya
un soutien de part et d'autre également
du désign mantin auprès des auprès des
exposants
alors c'est un peu on est on est désolés
de cette situation bien évidemment cette
annulation elle s'est fait à contrecoeur
d'autant que
cette année on avait d'intention aussi
de faire évoluer ce marché de noël
justement mettant en place des espaces
de restauration de telle sorte à ce que
voilà il puisse y avoir des
rassemblements très conviviaux
effectivement le contexte ne le permet
pas donc peut-être pour l'année
prochaine on espère qu on sorte de cette
crise sanitaire alors valérie vial une
telle initiative est ce que c'est
important à vos yeux et pourquoi avoir
accepté justement de faire partie aussi
de ce catalogue interactif
abbas est très important parce que on
est un peu seul dans notre atelier sinon
on doit battre client ait rien du tout
donc c'est un peu compliqué donc c'est
très bien ce que ce que les mairies la
mairie de montigny fait pour nous ici
est ce que la période des marchés noël
c'est très important dans fin d'année
pour vous est ce que vous en faites
beaucoup il y avait celui de montigny
qui était qui était proposée c'est une
période charnière pour vous la fin
d'année moi j'en fais à peu près six ou
sept
donc je crée bas toute l'année quasiment
et puis à partir du mois d'août fait
tout ce qui est pour noël mais c'est un
plus parce que moi je travaille pas
beaucoup de voix non en hiver donc du
coup si notre activité que je propose
pour les pour les clients et autres
à vendre des choses aussi sur tout ce
que je fais et donc c'est très important
que l'hiver moi je puisse travailler
aussi un peu et pas que l'était l'année
elle était comment pour vous elle a été
difficile
oui oui un petit peu j'ai eu un très bon
client donc j'ai eu la chance de
travailler pour le coc vide avec un un
gros client qui qui m'a donné pas mal de
gourou mais c'est très très peu par
rapport à d'habitude en fait présenter
votre activité vous êtes maître voilier
je le disais vous réparez notamment les
voiles ça parlera forcément aux
passionnés de voile en ce moment cette
période du vendée globe vous les
recycler aussi en créant des objets
c'est ça à partir de voiles qu'est ce
que vous faites si je fais des sacs des
pochettes j'utilise beaucoup de
matériaux char à voile parapente
ça peut être des cas il sort aussi donc
je fais des sacs doublés étanche des
pochettes chez des poufs je fais des
tables il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choix
pour garçons ou filles
il ya vraiment beaucoup de choix on voit
des images de votre atelier quand vous
étiez installé à coignières medic vous
êtes maintenant à elancourt on vous avez
suivi effectivement au cours d'un
reportage
et du coup ces produits oui vous le
disiez les marchés de noël c'est
l'occasion de vous faire connaître dans
ses produits de pouvoir les vendre aux
saint quentinois aux yvelinois
oui j'ai eu la chance de participer au
marché de noël depuis deux ans seulement
donc j'ai attendu ma place aussi ça
l'était un peu long mais j'étais super
content qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent et les gens sont très
intéressés même si j'achète pas ils sont
très curieux de poser des questions sur
mon métier et ainsi de suite et ça
j'adore partager ce que je fais c'est
vraiment une passion pour moi
donc même si ce qu'ils achètent pas
c'est un souci c'est de partager ce que
je suis en général
un dernier mot je vous ai cachin donc on
a vu on retrouve valérie vial dans ce
catalogue
on y retrouve d'autres artisans d'autres
exposants qui était prévu alors écoutez
pour être très précis
alors on est parti
sur 130 exposants encore cette année sur
les retours on a en tout cas sur la
constitution du catalogue
nous avons la répartition suivante nous
avons 80 exposants artisanat et une
cinquantaine d'exposants en tant que
commerçants alimentaires
nous avons eu un pourcentage de
participation qui correspond à 70 % en
ce qui concerne l'artisanat et à 50% ce
qui concerne l'alimentaire alors de là
quelques questions sont tarés parce que
bien évidemment on a aussi les gens qui
sont habitués aux commerçants qui pour
malheureusement on pouvait pas
participer à ce catalogue
moi je profite de l'occasion simplement
pour dire aux au public qu'aux visiteurs
que ils ont tout à fait la possibilité
d'envoyer un mail à événementiel @
montini 78 point fr qui le service se
chargera à ce moment là de leur
communiquer les coordonnées
téléphoniques pour que malgré tout voilà
ils puissent les contacter et peut-être
trouvé une solution pour faire leurs
commandes et on retrouve ce catalogue
interactif bien sûr un sur le site de la
mairie de montigny le bretonneux qui
s'est affichée d'ailleurs il ya des
liens qui permettent un des liens
d'accéder directement aux coordonnées
des commerçants des exposants qui
étaient prévus sur ce marché noël et qui
se retrouve donc au sein de ce catalogue
interactif merci à josé catieau mer
signant par les emplettes au maire
adjoint de la commune de montigny le
bretonneux en charge de la culture l
événementiel et valérie via louis an
dernier mot très rapide comme le marché
de noël ne venez pas il n'est pas
existants pour ce week-end ben je fais
une petite et ce pour eux chez moi
directement
donc j'ai ce pose en extérieur
le 4 5 6 et le 11 et 12 septembre
même pour discuter cinq minutes c'est
possible et on retrouve aux coordonnées
d'ailleurs dans chou à les attend allez
y aller que ce rendez vous par contre
malheureusement donc je prends que trois
personnes maximum par demi heure le
message est passé on retrouve vos
coordonnées au sein de ce catalogue
interactif qui est proposée par la
mairie de montigny-le-bretonneux merci
valérie vial d'avoir été avec nos
[Musique]
directions la verrière à présent la
commune a pris contact avec un
agriculteur du nord de la france la
semaine dernière une distribution de
pommes de terre a eu lieu sur le parking
du scarabée des sac de 15 kg vendu à
prix coûtant aux habitants de la commune
le reportage de nicolas landry des
centaines et des centaines de pommes de
terre du nord pour les verrières wade
sac de 15 kg vendu 5 euros à prix
coûtant une vente sur la journée
organisée à travers un système de drive
sur le parking du scarabée 15 clocher
cherchez bien pour les grandes familles
les nombreuses lors être pas mal
d'enfants et j'ai pas mal c'est pas moi
je sais pas cherché bénéfique pour
qu'ils montent généralement ils
fournissent beaucoup les restaurations
les restaurateurs là il se retrouve avec
une production sur les bras donc au lieu
de laisser sa dépérir et ben non ça nous
arrange eux ça les arrange
ce type d'opération une habitude pour ce
producteur depuis le déconfinement au
mois de mai 2020 plus de 300 tonnes de
pommes de terre ont été vendus ou donnés
à des associations
ce jour là ils sont venus avec 28 tonnes
chargé dans ce camion pour unité
justement de jeter cette nourriture
nous avons décidé de prendre des camions
il venir en ile de france on vend ses
pommes de terre
5 euros les 15 kg ce qui nous permet de
couvrir nos frais et couvrir les frais
de transport et de faire profiter de
produits français de qualité
justement aux consommateurs
ile de france pour la mairie de la
verrière c'est l'occasion de mettre à
disposition des habitants des produits
agricoles français mais pas seulement
il y aura également un don qui sera fait
à des associations caritatives
ce type d'opérations de vente directe va
effectivement s'intensifier avec
d'autres producteurs il faut qu'on
travaille plus intensément sur cette
dimension
prochain rendez vous pour le producteur
de pommes de terre du nord le jeudi 3
décembre à trappes sur la place des
merisiers depuis samedi la france
connaît donc une levée progressive des
restrictions concernant le confinement
les commerces peuvent ouvrir et nous en
parlions tout à l'heure et aussi
certains sports peuvent reprendre sont
de nouveau autorisés à être pratiqué
c'est le cas du golfe et au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ils étaient nombreux ce week-end sur le
parcours justin brasier michael et demi
d'euros les attendait cela depuis près
d'un mois depuis ce samedi 28 novembre
les golfeurs peuvent de nouveau taper la
petite balle blanche sur les parcours
évinois ils étaient des centaines sol et
green une affluence record au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jarret prend les airs et on sent bien
après avoir joué fans ont été ravis de
voir que le bol faisait partie des
premières activités outdoor qui
pouvaient réouvrir donc à la fois hier
et aujourd'hui on est venu profiter ont
la chance d'avoir un très beau temps en
plus ce week-end pour les accros gold
qu'on joue tous les week-ends et on
attendait l'ouverture avec impatience en
plus il faisait bout donc c'est un vrai
bonheur de venir jouer à hier et
aujourd'hui pour respecter les règles
sanitaires de ce second déconfinement le
protocole est toujours renforcer les
râteaux des bunkers sont retirés les
golfeurs ne doivent pas toucher le
drapeau du gel hydroalcoolique et
distribuer les parcours ont également
été raccourcie pour coller à la règle
des 20 km pendant une durée de 3 heures
maximum
on a divisé nos parcours pour en faire
des parcours 9 trous il ya qu'un seul
parcours qu'il n'a pas été touché par ça
c'est le parcours de l'oise et qui reste
un set trop mais effectivement on a la
chance de pouvoir dispatcher faire des
parcours composite avec
or trop et c'est trop le golf national
neuf trous en moins de trois heures une
mesure qui n'enthousiasme pas les
pratiquants on n'a pas le choix donc
c'est vrai que l'après midi on va faire
un peu de practice pour compenser et
puis neuf trous malgré tout c'est déjà
ça donc on a le temps de s'appliquer et
ça suffit personnellement je pense que
on peut largement faire plus maintenant
pour commencer pourquoi pas les golfs
yvelinois espère désormais le feu vert
des autorités pour pouvoir rouvrir
l'intégralité des parcours
le retour à la normale pourrait être
programmée le 15 décembre avant de vous
quitter elles sont arrivées à versailles
les 29 candidate pour le titre de miss
france 2000 21 séjourne depuis hier dans
la cité royale le comité miss france a
privatisé l'hôtel du trianon palace pour
ce séjour les prétendantes qui rêvent de
succéder à clémence bottineau s'y
préparent en vue de la cérémonie qui est
prévue le 19 décembre prochain au puy du
fou
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité l'information la
formation locale revient à dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]